Daryll is on the line in New York hi
Daryl how are you hi Dave thanks for
taking my call sure what's up so my wife
and I are in the process of closing on
the condo and we agreed to combine 2/3
of our finances into a family budget so
each of us brought that into the
marriage two years ago she brought in
her student loans and I brought in a
mortgage which is on what is now a
rental and I agreed to use my 1/3 to pay
down debt because I'm really into that
and I want to know that which one should
I pay off first mortgage or the student
loan you're not gonna like my answer I
don't like your plan at all
and here's why I'm an old-fashioned guy
and when the preacher says in sickness
and in health for richer for poorer unto
thee I pledge all my worldly goods if
you're you don't have a roommate dude
you have a wife and so you need to
combine 100% when you got her you got
all the good all the bad you got your
crazy mother-in-law and you got your
wonderful brother-in-law you got all the
good and you got the bad you got the
debt and you got her income you got all
the joy that she is and all the
heartache that she is that's called
being married and and she got all that
with you too so she doesn't have debt
anymore we have debt yeah that's what I
would do if I were in your shoes and to
not do that I think is a huge huge
mistake you're you're sowing seeds of
division in your relationship I think if
the two of you put your arms around each
other and hold really really tight
you've got a chance of surviving against
this mean old world but when you're
bifurcated like this and split up and
divided you're asking to be divided so
again I told you I didn't think you're
gonna like my answer but that's okay I'm
gonna tell you the truth anyway we have
seen more healing of marriages when we
force couples to combine their incomes
and combine their goals and combine
their debts than anything else we've
seen in Financial Peace University we've
seen a lot of people get out of debt a
lot of people become wealthy but the the
surprised the one that was a surprise
was we didn't know we were doing
marriage counseling and forcing people
to handle their money together forces
them to love each other well it forces
you to communicate at a level you don't
communicate otherwise and so dude you
really got to try it my way because I'm
completely right and your system is
screwed up hope that helps you hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]